husband in this case said that it was a
quick engagement
um two to three months before they got
engaged
two to three months and she was about 25
26 too right
uh 24 and he was 27. i think
okay right so quick engagement
and then seven to eight months later
they got married so
inside of a year they're married
um now that's probably not a little bit
rapid
yeah very rapid i mean it doesn't give
you much time to spot
uh like really dive deep into what
somebody's personality
really is how they'll how they'll deal
with stress when it's applied to the
relationship
what they're really all about i mean um
clinical psychologists will often tell
you that
people will behave or they'll behave
very well for the first couple years
like they can hide it
right and after the first couple years
and it becomes a lot more difficult for
them to
hide what their real personality is like
because we're always on our best
behavior
i mean you know people often say um or
i've heard often said
in law that you often find yourself
dating the representative and then when
you get married and say i do the
representative leaves and then you're
left with a real person
especially if you rush into it so you
need a couple years to really
you know i've used the term vetting
before but you can call it whatever you
want but you need a couple years
to watch the person and see what happens
when stress gets applied to the
relationship travel you know the luggage
gets lost see if she freaks out if she
can handle it
or not stuff like that right exactly you
know we did
uh before the train wreck on
narcissistic personality disorders and
narcissists
i don't think that this woman's a
narcissist but i don't really know
enough facts
and i'm not a clinical psychologist or a
psychiatrist to diagnose her
but if she were a covert narcissist it
could take
much longer than a year then he's in the
marriage and
kids right away they had kids like
within that first year after they got
married
yikes you know so that's a so that's a
big red flag is rushing into the
marriage obviously right
a couple months after he meets her gets
married within the year
they've got kids by the time they're 26.
but that's a lot of what the church
tells people
too right i think that if you're deeply
involved right down the rabbit hole
into that factory you've been felt a
steady diet of
have a big family do it now have it
quickly let's go
right uh husband said that he didn't see
any of this coming
um you know she dressed modestly
and she took a back seat uh to that
him being the head of the household so
maybe his radar was up maybe it wasn't
obviously he wasn't familiar with the
rational mail
or any of the other information that's
readily available out there
for vetting um so but at the same token
i mean when you
meet a woman and she's a skydiver and
rides motorcycles
and you're meeting them in korea
teaching english like
one of the things like i dated a woman
at one point that ran away from
canada to go live in japan to teach
english and one of the things i noticed
about it
and it and it happened a few times when
i was talking a few other um of her
friends that were also tied into the
group was that
they seem to be running away from
something right like why are you leaving
your country of origin
at a very young age to go out to the
orient to
teach english in a place where you're
not completely familiar with they always
had some
something pushing them out there it
seemed like they were leaving something
behind they
they had to depart from it they had to
run away from it sort of thing
you